now the secret behind any great burger
of course is the color making sure
you've got a nice beautiful color on
that burger patty get that pan nice
and warm
in we go
again
season it
salt
and pepper
as that starts
caramelizing a little touch of butter in
there just adds more and more flavor
start off high heat turn it down and use
the remaining heat in that pan to
continue cooking that burger beautifully
you can see
that the actual pate started to
caramelize you only flip burgers once
okay have the confidence use the pan let
the pan do the work and get that
beautiful color in there
i'm just going to give that a little
baste
there
so you can see what's happening
up
and over look at that color
touch more butter
[Music]
and because i've got all that beautiful
heat in the pan well i can get my onions
in there
and beautifully caramelize these onions
season the other side the burgers season
the onions again
fresh cracked pepper
and now this whole thing's starting to
come together
turn over my onions
beautiful
the flavor and the smell is incredible
we're literally cooking the burger two
minutes each side
i like my burgers just under medium
before i put my cheese on i like to
season
the burger again
cheese on
season the cheese
and again
one more
on top and then from there
[Music]
a touch of fresh pepper how do we melt
that cheese properly first of all
turn off the heat get your lid
stick that on top
and that will help melt that cheese
beautifully
set that to the side
and now for the exciting part this is
where we start to build this beautiful
burger my buns are being toasted okay so
that's going to give me a little bit
more
crispiness on there as well first of all
a little smear
of mayonnaise
soft butter lettuce just don't slice it
just crack that open let that sit nicely
again layer it up a touch of salt touch
a pepper it goes a long way tomato one
i'm going to get a little touch of
mustard
a beautiful dijon mustard and just rub
that
on the top part of my bun and then from
there i need some acid
i've got my pickles now
we are ready
lid off look at that cheese
it's melted beautifully
you can still hear that cook taking
place inside the pan
that's going to sit on top
and then finally
these onions look at them
caramelized beautifully
i just love the flavor
i just like to hit that
with a touch
fresh pepper
and then
bang
now come on
that is a burger to die for